[موسيقى]
وفق وكاله توضح الوثائق المسربه بالتفصيل
القدرات القتاليه لاوكرانيا ونقاط الضعف
المحتمله وخططها الحربيه كما تكشف عما وصف
بمعلومات عن جهود النيتو الواسعه لمساعده
في صد ما سمته الغزو الروسيه
تتحدث احدى الوثائق المسربه عن احتمال
مقتل ما بين
2017,500 جندي الروسي منذ بدء الحرب مقابل
ترجيح مقتل ما بين 61 الف واكثر من 71 الف
جندي اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
قالت ان بعض الوثائق تكشف عن الاسلحه
الامريكيه المستخدمه من قبل اوكرانيا
والتدريبات التي خضعت لها القوات
الاوكرانيه اعتبارا من مرسى الماضي كما
اشارت الى الانظمه الاضافيه وبرامج
التدريب التي من المتوقعي ان تتمتع بها
كيابل لاحقا وفق وسائل اعلام امريكيه حملت
التسريبات ايضا ما يبدو انها معلومات
استخباراتيه امريكيه بشان برنامج ايران
النووي وبرنامج الصواريخ لكوريا الشماليه
والصين ومناطق اخرى من العالم
[موسيقى]